[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studio it's the ramsay show
where america hangs out to have a
conversation about your life your money
your career your relationships you name
it
i'm george campbell and i'm joined today
by my colleague good friend fellow
ramsay personality and best-selling
author ken coleman ken it's good to have
you good to be with you george i love
when you introduce me if i should record
that and play that when i walk in the
house it's inspirational look at me
differently if nothing else it's
inspirational it's a free call folks
give us a call with your questions
triple eight eight two five five two two
five it is toll-free as of today and i
think it will stay that way is it right
is it you just made it toll-free i just
made it toll free by the way it's funny
nobody says toll free anymore i think we
should bring it back i think so too out
of tradition saying yeah that's what i
grew up with toll free well it's going
to be a fun friday with me and ken at
the helm uh and we're taking your calls
so give us a call and uh don't be scared
a lot of people listening right now are
going yeah i've never called i've always
wanted to
but i just i don't want to get on the
line especially if you're a millennial
millennials are scared of phone calls
ken did you know that is that right yeah
it's because they've never talked to
anybody we don't like we just
but that doesn't make for great radio
does it no but i'll tell you this uh
john delaney and i said this yesterday i
say this every day on the ken coleman
show and john says it on the on the dr
john deloney show because of the
sensitivity of the calls we take you
know i got people calling every day
going uh i'm having a real problem at
work my boss is uh is a pill a jerk or
uh or just hey i'm i'm burned out i want
to go over here and they don't want
somebody you know that they work with to
overhear it because it's a national show
and so i i wanted to point out uh today
as we did yesterday as i do every day on
the coma show we'll change your name
we'll change your location uh jenna's on
the phones over there she's been trained
by the best in the business kelly daniel
and we take care of you we understand
the sensitivity to some of these calls
and so we want you to feel that extra
blanket of safety to know that george
and i will never know if that's your
real name or where you're from and quite
frankly we don't care we just wanna care
about you so yeah uh i think there are
some people today that have been
listening for a while and they're going
okay
um these guys don't look terribly
intimidating and honestly look at us if
you're watching on youtube right now how
could you possibly be intimidated by
these two guys yeah i don't know i don't
win many fights ken let's put that out
there yeah but i don't even fight we are
here triple eight eight two five five
two two five we're kicking it off with
rodolfo in salem oregon rodolfo welcome
to the ramsay show how are you
pretty good on yourself doing great how
can we help today
so yeah my question is uh
well six grand in credit card loan debt
uh
i was just trying to see where should i
start off uh should i pay off at once
uh little by little
you know i'm just i just want to say
where do i start basically
so let me recap you've got six thousand
dollars in credit card debt is this
across multiple cards
uh two cards two cards
okay uh are you familiar with with our
baby steps that we teach
uh a little not
i mean i know it's uh the one thousand
dollar emergency uh
you know for just in case something
happens yeah do you have that so far do
you have a thousand dollars
yeah i do yeah i have more than that you
have more than that how much more are we
talking
i have about eight grand
hold up you have eight grand in cash and
you have six grand in credit card debt
yeah this is an easy math equation for
me what's what's been holding you back
from just going ahead and paying that
whole thing off in one lump sum
well basically you know i i bought this
travel trailer as well um i'm remodeling
it so basically it's gonna cost me about
four grand to possibly
after that
so you've been hanging on to it for the
remodel
yeah yeah i'm just basically yeah that
that's what's been holding me holding me
up basically okay and this is your only
debt this credit card debt
i have a car as well i took out a i
bought a truck
okay what's what's the loan on that
truck
uh right now it is 26 io26
okay
well you've got baby step one down which
is that thousand dollar starter
emergency fund and now you're in baby
step two where you're paying off all of
your consumer debt uh except the house
and this includes the truck too so what
i would start with is your smallest debt
first that's what we teach the debt
snowball
so you're going to list all of your
debts from smallest to largest we're
ignoring the interest rate we're not
concerned with that we're concerned with
progress and we're concerned with
actually seeing this debt gone so as of
today you can have no credit card debt
with the cash you have on hand correct
yeah correct that'll leave you with 2
000 you can take 1 000 of that and start
attacking that truck loan
and i want that thing gone before you
start doing all these renovations on on
the trailer i mean is there any urgency
around the trailer renovations
uh not too much i just wanted to split
it
so yeah basically okay so this was a
quick money-making scheme for you
just trying of flip the truck make some
money
yeah okay well before before we do that
we got to clean this up
as well so rodolfo let's put a new
timeline together okay george told you
exactly what to do are you tracking as
to why you need to do it that way and
that it is something you're going to do
is that a yes are you going to do this
the do what
the debt snowball the debt snowball what
george just told you to do you got to
pay that debt off today
yeah well that's the thing so i should i
should pay it off then that's what you
recommend yes
absolutely i mean
how much is this truck worth i'm curious
uh
right now it's worth about 42. it's
worth 42 and you have a 26 000 loan
yeah
what do you think about selling that
truck since you're not underwater on it
and using that cash
to
really get your life started
well i i thought about that i do
as well
you do what now sorry speak clearly into
the phone we we missed you
but landscaping you so you need it for
your business
yeah no you don't you don't need a 42
000 truck that's a nice truck for a
landscape i know i know that you know
but no no no hold on a second hold on a
second i'm not in a butt mood today all
right i'm just gonna jump in here george
all right yeah listen to me dude
let's just run the math
you owe 26 on the truck it's worth 42.
if i heard that correctly i'd flip that
by the weekend 16 grand
now you got 16 grand you can go buy
something a decent older truck or
whatever that you need for the 16 and
you can flip the trailer and everything
else and now you're rocking and rolling
man and we're talking about fast
forwarding here we got a point there you
got a point there what i'm hearing is
you could be debt free this week if you
wanted to yeah and then you can be cash
flowing these renovations get a cheaper
truck for the landscaping gig and
upgrade yeah as you get more cash flow
in and let me remind you once you get
rid of that car loan and these credit
cards you're going to have more income
you're going to get a raise because
you're not making payments anymore
that's true so i want that to fuel you
get you excited about the future because
i can tell you're a sharp dude
entrepreneurial type and you're going to
set yourself up way better for the
future if you can clean this mess up
this week and start to have that cash
flow back in your life
okay yeah i think i'm i'm going to do
that for sure probably try to try taking
my truck to carmax or something to see
what they yeah dude absolutely there's
so many options right now carmax
dealerships vroom carvana you name it
but get the best uh bang for your buck
there and uh we believe in you man you
got this you can get rid of this debt
get these uh this income back in your
life that is the key this is the ramsay
show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
if you're ready to get out there and
find a job you love then you need to
hear this
job hunting can be stressful and time
consuming but my friends at zip
recruiter have made the whole job search
way easier ziprecruiter is rated the
number one job site in the us by g2 and
it's free so how does it work
first go to ziprecruiter.com
ken
then create a free profile and let their
technology do the hard work by finding
and sending you jobs that are a great
fit and get this
zip recruiter pitches your profile to
companies whose jobs match your skills
and experience if someone from that
company likes your profile they can
personally invite you to apply for the
job so if you're ready for an easier job
search check out ziprecruiter sign up
for free right now at ziprecruiter.com
ken that's
ziprecruiter.com
ken sign up today absolutely free and
let zip recruiter work for you
[Music]
825-5225 is the number if you want to
give us a call i'm george campbell
joined by my friend ken coleman here hey
if you're like most people you've got
more than enough on your mind right now
you're getting the kids where they need
to be you're keeping up with the bills
you're staying on top of work and family
it's exhausting and it can be stressful
but money doesn't have to be one more
thing you worry about when you have the
right plan you can be in control of your
money and your life and that plan is
financial peace university
this class will show you step by step
how to pay off debt save money and build
wealth for the future you can stream all
nine lessons on your own or you can join
a class with other people so you're not
figuring it out alone
and now the only way to experience fpu
is with a ramsey plus membership this
plan works every time just ask the six
million people who've done it and never
worry about money anymore i'm one of
them and you guys can do it too to start
your free trial of ramsay plus and check
out fpu just text the word trial to
three three
seven eight nine that's trial two three
three seven eight nine hersey is in
ottawa canada hersey welcome to the
ramsay show
hi thank you very much for having me
glad to have you how can we help today
uh so i had a quick question so i
graduated college about like a year ago
um i have no debt i have um yes i've
been living at home i make great income
i work with the federal government
and i've just been trying to figure out
what my next steps should be so i was a
little confused in that department
should i
start a business should i try something
new so i'm just looking like future
career-wise like i'm i'm like i'm in a
great place right now but just looking
more towards the future what should i do
now kind of what i'm confused about you
said you have a great job already
yes what is that job
a computer system so i work with the
federal government so fixed computers
network issues uh troubleshooting
uh so a bunch of different things
related to computers yeah so what do you
wonder about you you went to college you
you uh clearly got some type of
technical training and you've got a good
job you don't despise it but you're a
young man and you're calling going what
are my next steps and i throw to you i
go well we'll determine the steps once
we know what mountain we want to climb
so you got this thing all backwards so
we figure out okay what what is it that
i want to do with my professional life
is there purpose and work and their
answer is yes
and so
uh i want to know what you're wondering
about because i know you're wondering
about something so what are you
wondering about
um
i'm wondering more towards like because
there's always this big step forward
following graduate school get a good job
keep working and then now that i've
accomplished
all of that
i'm in a place where i'm like okay what
should i accomplish now so what should
my next goal be what should i be
focusing towards now should i start a
silence or like a business on the side
or should i
so it's not like i am happy where i am
but i feel like i'm just a little
ambitious and i'm just
yeah so it's wonderful i totally get it
hersey i totally get everything you said
but you didn't answer my question
uh so so let me give you a little bit of
context and then i'm gonna hit you again
all right
because i think you've got an answer
okay
so
the goals and the steps again are
determined
by our direction it's not okay i went
and got a degree i've got a good job so
do i get a master's degree next what's
the next task i got to do that's going
to lead you to a life of wandering
wondering is what was i put on this
planet to do so
on the ken coleman show and i'm a part
of ramsey solutions so my entire
methodology is this
you use what you do best talent
to do work you love
passion to produce results that matter
to you mission do you get that statement
yes sounds pretty darn good doesn't it
it does so what we got to do is we got
to fill in the blanks what are your top
talents
what's the kind of work that you love to
do high emotion high devotion you think
about it you get excited when you're in
the middle of it time seems to stand
still and then the ultimate piece is
what results do i want my work to
produce what is my contribution to the
world you've got to start to wrestle
with that and again you're sharp enough
of a young man you've accomplished some
things you're living at home you've
wondered about something so let's just
put you to the test hersey what would
you try tomorrow
if you knew you couldn't fail guaranteed
couldn't fail but
you didn't have to commit the rest of
your working life to it so it's a big
fun professional
what would you do
um
probably start an online business of
some sort great i love making websites i
love uh i love playing with applications
and then i've always wanted to really
give that a try see where it goes i
don't have a background in business i i
have some ideas of it uh supply demand
of course i love investing i invest a
lot um
so here's the deal hersey you've already
started allowing doubt to creep in you
gave me a little bit of a fun answer
then you immediately came up with all
the reasons why it might not be possible
i don't want any more disclaimers hersey
you said
uh that you loved the idea uh and you
shared the idea and so you need to start
tinkering around with that right start
doing it start doing it on the side uh
for yourself or get a part-time job
doing it for somebody else at nights or
weekends you're working in a government
job the federal government canada's got
to be as slow and as boring as the
federal government jobs in the united
states you've got time to do this here's
what i want you to do two things i want
you to to literally start to tinker to
try some things get some projects either
do it for yourself or do it for somebody
else then i want you to actually get on
the phone
and i want you to talk to people via
zoom coffee
lunch whatever who do this kind of work
and in doing so hersey you're going to
learn the ends the outs the good the bad
and the ugly around that type of work
plus you're going to get a lot of ideas
you're going to get suggestions you're
going to get connections to have more of
those conversations and before you know
it hersey here's what happens
in the process of clarifying what all's
involved in that work that you've always
kind of been interested in and wondering
about
your heart will verify if in fact you do
want to do that does that make sense yes
that makes that makes total sense so
stop thinking and start getting busy
start connecting start trying start
doing and watch what happens
i love this
percy what's your degree in i'm curious
computer systems
okay so you love you love computers and
you love building websites and you don't
you don't have to have business
experience to start an online business
oh you've got this and because you're
excited about it you're going to learn
along the way and it's going to be fun
and you can do this on the side while
you still have this government job and
you start to get legs under this
business and you get more clients or
whatever that thing is you want to do
and all of a sudden you're going to go
wow i've got 10 clients i can take this
thing full time 100 and 2 george's
advice here he's right hersey why don't
you go find somebody a small non-profit
uh or a a family that's got a child
that's overcome some physical challenge
and they're trying to raise money for
themselves or maybe for other kids
something small something local and they
got a really crappy website and why
don't you go hey
i'm going to design a site for you for
free that's my donation and do that and
then get better at it do it again and do
it again and do it again and then to
start to charge for it
this is not you don't have to have a
business degree to do this
no it's true no that's completely true i
guess i had a little a little bit of
doubt on how to take that big that big
step because eventually i do want to be
my own boss but i do want to have my own
business and uh knock them into a nice
fight so
so that's beautiful hershey you don't
have to take a big step the advice i
just gave you those are little teeny
tiny shuffles and that's the beauty of
this we don't want you to take a big
step either not only a very stable job
uh you don't need to leap you need to
step and step in step in step and uh by
the way that's how we climb ladders i've
never seen somebody successfully climb
ladders by jumping two rungs at a three
rungs it feels dangerous ken it's how
you blow your knee out or break a leg or
even worse so uh keep on stepping young
man this does not have to be that scary
and by the way welcome to being a human
because doubt comes at us all
and i will give you this last piece of
advice hersey we just walked through a
little shortened version of getting
clear
and when doubt starts to creep up on
your shoulder and say you don't have
what it takes
or no one's going to pay you to do a
website or whatever doubt says i want
you to retreat to clarity and i want you
to retreat to clarity by saying why do i
love designing websites why do i love
tinkering with apps so why do i love to
do that and then your heart will remind
you why and that'll keep you going yeah
that's the education system ken get the
degree get the job and i still don't
have the purpose yeah you've got to stop
your skull because you have no idea what
your soul is telling you to do
you got this hersey man we're rooting
for you this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
i'm george campbell joined by ken
coleman this is the ramsay show it's a
free call triple eight eight two five
five two two five
john joins us in akron ohio john welcome
to the ramsay show how can we help
hey how's it going guys thanks for
taking my call here
so i'm calling today um just got married
a couple weeks ago and my new wife and i
were very happy and to be together and
thank goodness we've been very fortunate
we don't have
any debts
or loans or anything like that we both
just graduated
um
college in may
i'm currently in the
reason i'm calling today
is because i'm currently working as a
tennis instructor
and making about 60k a year and
as passionate as i am about tennis
we're struggling to
[Music]
were struggling with the lifestyle of
that job because
you know you have to be available
when
the eight to five people are getting off
work or when kids are getting off school
so most of my hours at work are
weekday evenings and weekend mornings
and we're just really struggling with it
and we're coming to the realization that
i don't think this is
i just like i just don't know if this is
what i want to do for the next
40 years so i was excited to hear when
ken was on the show today
just you know to bring this career
question to him and just kind of wanted
to
uh
get you guys advice um i've been doing a
lot of listening to
uh mike rowe
um about you know opportunities and the
skills you have that we have in this
country when particularly as it
uh
pertains to trades like plumbers
electricians and so forth so i just kind
of wanted to like
ask for some general guidance because i
guess i'm at the point where it's like
i'm happy doing what i'm doing now
but at some point i want to go to work
when the rest of the world goes to work
you know when
my family wants to have dinner on a
tuesday night you know i want to be
available you know that's kind of what
i'm that's kind of what we're up against
right now i totally get it but the
reality is that's not where you are
right now you're a newlywed and so while
the rest of the while you're doing uh
tennis lessons
on weeknights
and early saturday mornings you got all
day long
to be doing something with yourself and
making some progress here
so i think that there is a there is uh
there's a whole lot of hope there i
don't want you to feel like you know uh
well i gotta make this decision right
now um because i feel like you're
calling about a situation where if
you've got young kids and everything
else i think it makes sense but right
now you said you're passionate about
tennis instructing so i've got a
question
if you were uh if you were working uh
nine to five
would you be calling me right now
if you were a tennis instructor from
nine to five right now would you be
calling us with this question
uh
i don't think so
no i don't i would i would probably say
no okay so what does that tell you
it's not that you don't want to be a
tennis instructor it's that you're
you're like going way ahead to where
you've got little kids and you're not
there man you've been married what two
weeks
well a couple months i'm sorry couple
months but yeah
my point holds
you wouldn't be calling me
to talk about this
if you were doing tennis instructing
from eight to five
so i now that begs the question where
can you do tennis instruction
during the hours
of eight to five
right
no no that's not the answer there's an
answer where can you do tennis
instructing during the day tell me
oh man
um florida or
you know um
a world world class you know tennis
academy where
the kids go there
to live eat and breathe tennis or
or maybe uh you're a tennis coach um you
know at a uh
at a uh you know a racket you know one
of those like uh it's all racket
communities and maybe or maybe you're a
tennis teacher at a school and you're
doing several things i mean you've just
basically came you've just come to this
conclusion that oh man the only way i
can do this work that i really love
is uh
weeknights and weekends and i'm never
going to see my family so my life is
going to suck so i'm going to start
watching mike rowe to figure out a trade
really
yeah
you hear how that sounds
so let me encourage you that's why i
asked you the question you want you love
tennis you love teaching tennis you've
got to ask yourself
where can i do that and then what's the
latter look like so let's have another
little fun experiment
take me you know the tennis world way
better than i do okay tennis instructor
you know that world better than i do
take me up the ladder
like what what would be a potential like
amazing job like 5 10 15 20 years from
now right now you're a tennis instructor
but what's way up above you in the
tennis world give me a couple of options
well let's see being the director at a
private club
um
is a step is a couple steps above
um
becoming the head pro of a head pro
is like a step below
tennis director yeah and then
um
from that above that would just be like
um
part ownership okay and of a facility
okay i guess that's kind of yeah now
how when you start walking your mind
through those how desirable those become
to you
just in the moment
at the moment um
well i know that they you know you
definitely when you get to that point
you have more
say over your schedule so
and um
a greater much greater deal of autonomy
so
i mean they sound they sound pretty good
okay so here's my point i'm not going to
take you a different direction today
because i haven't heard at any point in
this phone call that you don't love
instructing tennis that you aren't
passionate about tennis you are you've
just gotten ahead way ahead of your life
schedule right now and you've created a
problem that doesn't exist
and you know what if if it's moving from
akron ohio you and your new wife need to
discuss hey where is tennis really big
where is a great future in tennis are we
willing to go there i think that's a
conversation over steak and a glass of
wine you understand what i'm saying
yeah yeah i hear you so here's the deal
brother i'm happy to help steer you
another direction but i don't hear
another direction because i'm going to
tell you what i tell everybody if it's
not using your talent
to do work you love to produce a result
that matters to you you shouldn't do it
whether micro tells you it's a good
opportunity or not because you're going
to be miserable
yeah
you with me
yeah no i'm hearing you
so i i think your next steps are
to really dive into what a great looking
future could look like in tennis and
then let that be the conversation that
you have with yourself and your wife
but don't get out of it right now i
think it's a terrible move oh by the way
you got all this time between eight to
five for do research and making
connections and looking for other gigs
in the local area so get busy
get busy don't make the change yet
this is a great problem to have ken he's
making 60k as a tennis instructor
basically after hours yeah he's going to
hold up he's got his days wide open and
this is an interesting predicament i
don't know how often you run into it but
someone who's doing something they love
but it's not at the right place or the
right times yeah right so what we don't
do is throw out the thing we love well
find a new career down the road this is
gonna be really rough on family life so
i'm gonna
i gotta find a trade right now what
no no no no no don't throw out passion
and mission that's what you love to do
and results you love to create don't
throw that out
just don't it's it's
let's at least do some research and go
wait a second where could i go over here
now i'm gonna tell you something right
now if i put this young man in a you
know if he go if he moves to florida
it's his idea and he gets a great job
probably making the same amount of money
he's making now but he pays his dues
and he goes well i can make 120 grand
being the tennis director at the boca
del vista you know resort for seniors
sounds real he'd be out of his mind
happy yeah
based on what he said yeah john call us
back when you are the director of an
athletic club call ken coleman show and
say hey ken you were right i'm glad i
didn't decide to be an electrician i'm
sitting with marty and margaret and i'm
teaching them how to play tennis they're
fabulous this is good times can i love
what you do on the ken coleman show and
i love when you get to bring a little
bit of that little taste of that to the
ramsay show so i'm grateful to have you
on we've got more of this where that
came from more of the ramsay show coming
up
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
this is the ramsay show i'm george
campbell joined by my friend ken coleman
we are taking your calls on money life
relationships whatever's going on your
life let's talk about it it's a free
call triple eight eight two five
five two two five serena joins us in
paducah kentucky serena welcome to the
ramsay show
hi thank you what's going on
um i was curious to know
how can you get creditors of like credit
card companies um to work with you more
say like if i was to call them and try
to pay an actual small credit card debt
off
how to pay the least amount as possible
because i'm hitting a brick wall with a
few of them of not wanting to budge at
all what have the conversations been
like so far like you call and you say
what
uh well i just tell them that i'm
wanting to pay off the credit card uh in
full
and they basically like i've got
received a letter that you know tells me
an amount that they'll
accept for a benefit paid in full
and i'm just
trying to figure out is that the actual
amount that i need to go by or is there
ways around it to maybe even
get around it to pay less
well the the short answer is more on
another deal
if i go 2 000 in debt i owe 2 000 in
debt now there is there are some
clarifications if this is an older debt
how old is this debt that you're paying
off
um they're just a little few odds and
end credit cards is this like a year old
is it five years old
probably
um
they just started going delinquent
probably three to four months ago so
this is pretty reasonable until then
okay
so when when more time has gone by you
have a better chance because at this
point there's very there's little hope
as time goes on that they're going to
get their money back and so they're
willing to take less but with a fresh
debt you may not be able to negotiate it
down as much as you'd like now you can
always make an offer have you tried that
where you just call them and say hey
this is what i i've got to cover my my
light bills i got to keep food on the
table i have 50 left over
will that suffice or if i paid you a
thousand dollars in full for the two
thousand dollars of debt would you clear
it have you tried something like that
no i have not
because you've been asking them hey what
is it what does it take to pay off the
debt in full and they say it's two
thousand dollars and you say okay that's
been the conversation so far
correct what are the numbers how many
small cards and what are the numbers on
each
um there's probably
six total
probably a combined of 2500
um my debt and all i mean like with a
furniture loan a pool loan and then just
all the little credit cards
like some of them are like just a little
home
like little malls small stores and then
some of them are like citibank
um so you're saying you have six credit
cards and it's about 2500 combined of
all six
yes
okay i mean honestly this is just not
that much money
we're not negotiating two hundred
thousand dollars down to 50. yeah but
and that's my situation like i hear all
these amazing inspiring stories with
these
astronomical numbers and i'm just like
why can i not do this small little bitty
amount but to give you a little bit of
background um
just recently got married in june
a month after being married
my husband got let go from his job
and we went from having like a steady
income knowing what was going to come in
every single week that he was paid
to him going to be a car salesman
and working 100
commission pay
however that was very um traumatizing
and worrisome for me
just because i
did not know what to expect on how to
account
to figure out like how much money is
going to come in because we just never
know
but i will say he is
killing it he is making tripled him out
that he was making up the other job
awesome and
but i know there's going to be a down
period and i want to be able to
have you know the emergency funds
there's three months worth of expenses
you know like i want all that in line as
well so i don't know how much
current money to let go of how much how
much money do you have right now in cash
in the bank
uh cash in the bank probably
seven thousand
okay i want this debt out of your life
today i don't think it's worth i mean
you can try to negotiate but i would
just pay this 2500 off and move on with
your life and continue in the debt
snowball uh because you have the cash
and that means you're gonna go back to a
thousand with the starter emergency fund
as you attack these debts i want you to
have this financial stability but right
now you're trying to do 48 things at
once and we've got to clean up a mess of
a spending spree that you know it
sounded like it was a fun joy ride while
it lasted but now you're kind of faced
with the reality of looking in the
mirror saying we don't want to live like
this right
serena how much was your husband making
before the car job
um before the car job probably
between 33 and 35 000 a year
you told me then and george that he's on
pace to make 90 this year you said three
times were you just exaggerating or were
you being literal
i'm being literal like him okay well
where's that money here's let me let me
analyze that a little bit his first
paycheck
was three times the amount it would have
been had he worked at his current job a
month but that's just you don't ever
know like how the car sells sure but
where did that money go yeah right we
understand that where is all that money
you said he's killing it and then you
told george he got seven grand well if
he's killing it then somebody stole it
or you gave it away or yeah what's
happening all this extra money
well i mean we have already paid off
some debt with that money okay and then
you know i mean there's just everyday
bills that we have you know the main
four ones
okay so here's the deal you called about
should i negotiate a settlement on these
credit cards and george is absolutely
right they're not that delinquent enough
you don't have enough leverage and quite
frankly you don't need to i appreciate
that you want to save some money
everybody likes saving money george is
like the guru
save money but here's the deal
the baby steps are the baby steps
okay
that's what they are and so you get a
thousand dollars in your
emergency fund that's it you're trying
to do baby step three before finishing
baby step two george is right do what he
said knock out the 2500 as quick as
possible
then those things are gone from your
life cut them up don't ever go back to
them again
and then you guys should be super tight
until your husband starts getting in a
rhythm and then we have those bigger
checks we build the emergency fund but
you're worried about something that
quite frankly you shouldn't be worried
about serena are you guys on a written
budget right now
uh
tentatively yeah it's like that's
that's still a lot of confidence in me
yes we are on a written play needs
definitively no actually he he's on
board but
not on board he's one foot in the boat
and one foot in the water so i kind of
feel like i'm doing it alone okay well
here's what i want to do for you guys
i'm gonna have uh kelly and jenna pick
up and they're gonna gift you guys a
year of ramsay plus and inside of ramsay
plus i want you two to go through
financial peace university there's nine
lessons you can binge em if you want do
it on your own time but i need you guys
to get on the same page otherwise you're
going to be calling me back in six
months with more debt and more
frustration and more stress
and i want you to follow the baby steps
that are outlined in financial peace
university and with ramsay plus you're
also going to get access to every dollar
plus that's our premium budgeting tool
it'll connect your bank account so you
can track your spending even easier you
guys need to get on rice and beans and
start tracking every dollar coming in
including all the extra money that he's
got coming in and you need to clean up
this mess so that you can have that
financial stability that you told me you
wanted right that's your why is you want
financial stability right
right
and to get there we have to follow these
baby steps because right now you're
biting off a lot more than you can chew
you're trying to clean up this this debt
that's in collections
uh i want you to clean up this debt
today call them pay them be done with it
now i want you to do it on your terms
don't give them access to your checking
account you can do a cashier's check a
money order and make sure that it's on
your terms be proactive with them let
them know where you're at with this but
i don't think this is a long-term thing
that you're negotiating for six months
you're calling them today and saying hey
what's the total great
here's the cashier's check i'm done with
this and move on to your next debts and
your next debt until they're all cleaned
up and then guess what's going to happen
all of this extra income coming in stays
with you it's not going back out to
lenders
and then you can build up that three to
six months emergency fund start
investing and hopefully you guys are on
the same page once you have this
financial stability and you've gone
through financial peace university how's
that sound
sounds great let's go serena all right
well that puts this hour of the ramsey
show in the books i want to thank jenna
our phone screener ben hill our producer
and you america for tuning in ken and i
will be back before you know it until
then spend wisely save intentionally and
give generously
[Music]
have a friend or family member that
needs a daily dose of ramsey advice in
their life let them know about the
ramsey call of the day podcast it's a
quick hit of advice about life and money
in under 10 minutes check out the ramsey
call of the day podcast wherever you
listen to podcasts
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studio it's the ramsay show
where america hangs out to have a
conversation about your life and your
money and your purpose and your career
and all sorts of things i'm george
campbell ramsey personality joined by
fellow ramsay personality ken coleman
host of the ken coleman show aptly named
and we're taking your calls and it's a
free one triple eight eight two five
five two two five paul joins us in
houston texas paul welcome to the ramsay
show
thank you thanks george thanks ken uh
for taking the call uh so
i'm new to the ramsey program itself um
i discovered it here trying to figure
out how to pay off all my debts and
before i had been doing some
probably
less than ideal things um with my
finances
so
my question is with this pandemic
should i adhere to the one thousand
dollars
in an emergency fund or
should i have that
uh multiplied
by a certain amount
so you're wondering because of the
pandemic because of what's going on with
the economy how does this affect me do i
need to save up two thousand ten
thousand forty thousand in an emergency
fund
right right i've got some other
circumstances going but this
besides the point but i want to make
sure that
i'm doing everything i possibly can yeah
well paul since you're new to the plan
i'll go easy on you but there is no paul
caveat in the ramsey plan that says well
if your name's paul and you live in
houston yeah it's okay to save more the
purpose of this uh is not to instill
fear and have you walking on thin ice
the purpose of the thousand dollars is
to fuel you to pay off all of your
consumer debt to get you the stability
so if you have a little fear i want you
to i want you to be a little bit
uncomfortable because if when you get
comfortable you get broke
and so the purpose of this thousand
dollars is not to say hey if the hvac
goes out you're not gonna be able to
cover it the purpose is to get you angry
enough with this debt and get you scared
enough because you're not in a good
place right now when you have all this
debt so the purpose of that is to fuel
you through baby step two which is the
debt snowball paying off all of your
consumer debts except for the mortgage
to get you to baby step three where we
create this financial force field
between you and life between you and the
pandemic so you were talking about your
circumstances there paul what are those
circumstances
um
so
over the past about five years i've
doubled my income which is great awesome
but
i
unfortunately was letting someone else
manage the money um
and i discovered back in december just
how
it was managed
it was definitely not um
in financial best interests
was it a spouse or what what do you mean
someone else was managing the money
it was it was a spouse
since since then i
had to take the reins and
it obviously caused a big turmoil and a
separation
to occur i'm sorry i said enough's
enough
we've
we've got
100 grand plus coming in
why why do we have 99 000 going out
so you weren't you guys obviously
weren't on the same page with money you
didn't know what was going on with the
money you actually did financial peace a
number of years ago
but it didn't stick clearly obviously
obviously didn't
this was part to her and i meeting many
years ago
so you guys are separated now is it is
there a divorce being finalized
uh
not as of yet but i need to get
everything on pace because i do have a
son that i have to take care of
i'm sorry to hear that paul
and i'm 191 thousand dollars
in the hole with
a mortgage
oh the mortgage what is the other type
of debt the non-mortgage debt that you
have credit card credit card vehicle um
back taxes um unpaid homeowners
association fees
what does that all add up to the
consumer debt uh about about forty nine
thousand forty nine what's your your uh
income
and that's you solo which i'm guessing
you will be is your money separated yet
are you back in the range completely
separated okay so you got 126 coming in
and you have 49 in consumer debt so that
gives me hope because you've got a big
shovel uh and to me this debt is gone in
a year
with your with your take-home pay you
can absolutely crush this debt using the
debt snowball method
so what that is saying to me is you've
got a thousand dollars saved for a year
while you clean up this mess and then
you're gonna very quickly get the three
to six months in place and have that
financial stability
yeah paul i got a question here is
george is walking you through this
you're very new to the ramsey solutions
process how's your budget right now you
got you got every dollar accounted for
you figured it out have you tightened
things up
i
definitely
accounted for every dollar here i
actually downloaded the um every dollar
app right a couple days ago and
started excel spreadsheet and after i've
already done
basically i started out doing baby step
three before anything
right
so but i've got an estate put up um now
what do you got what's in your baby step
three that's out of out of order what's
in it uh about
13 000.
okay
so you got 13 000 in cash right now
yes is that is that in addition to the
1000 or that includes the 1000 that we
say needs to be the emergency fund
that's including the 1000 emergency fund
okay well you heard george walk you
through this you heard george walk you
through this and i know you're new to it
but the reason that dave ramsey taught
it this way is because it's all about
psychology and momentum do you
understand there is some actual science
behind it it's not just dave's opinion
and the momentum is this
with a thousand dollars in your
emergency fund baby step one now you
take 12 000 today
what's the next
what's the smallest debt you've got
right now what is it
uh
about 1200.
okay what's next what's next is that a
credit card
yeah that's a small credit card all
right what's next after that
uh home overseas um another
almost two thousand okay what's next
after that
uh another credit card well how much is
that one
uh 45
no i'm sorry 49.
okay i'm doing quick math here that's
got uh
yeah i'm counting we still got money to
spend how much what's next after that
we're wiping these out what's next after
that every by the way if you're keeping
up with me paul every one of these
things you're telling me you're paying
off with that twelve thousand today
right right and i also have a personal
loan um out uh because i did so uh
upside down real estate property i'm in
preparation for how much is that
uh eight thousand okay we're not gonna
okay so we're not gonna get to that one
but the idea is is george walked you
through you're gonna go smallest largest
so we're gonna spend twelve thousand
dollars today before you go to bed
tonight you're wiping out several debts
we just got the three we don't have to
keep walking through this on the air and
paul what that does it takes you down to
37 and when you're making 126 you're
gonna clean this thing up in six or
seven months and you'll probably get
gazelle intense and want to take a side
job and work more and clean this thing
up even faster so that you can create
financial stability for yourself for
your kid that's what it's all about paul
that is why we teach the baby steps in
order and you got this man follow the
steps you can do it this is the ramsay
show
[Music]
life is full of firsts
[Music]
as the first and longest-serving
christian health cost sharing ministry
chm has shared medical expenses for its
members since 1981.
we believe you should have the freedom
to focus on your health while being
supported by a community of believers
giving you the opportunity to create
many more firsts
[Music]
so
[Music]
this is the ramsay show i'm george
campbell joined today by ken coleman
it's a pre-call triple 825-5225
no parent ever wants their child to
experience the panic of being unprepared
for an emergency but teaching your teens
how to be smart with money can feel like
a big job we've got your back with our
digital self-study courses you can rest
assured that your teen will know the
right way to handle money no matter what
curveballs life may throw them down the
road and the best part no instructor
needed that's right if your teen has a
tablet or a computer they're all set so
parents text self study one word self
study to 33789 to learn more about all
the different courses we have available
for your middle or high schooler
we've got our blinds.com question of the
day here find out for yourself why
blinds.com is the number one online
retailer of custom window covering you
get free samples free shipping and with
the new promos they run every month
you'll save even more use promo code
ramsay to get the best deal rules and
restrictions apply today's question
comes from drew in minnesota i'm a 32
year old graphic designer married with
two young children we have no debt
except for our mortgage i design
full-time for a very large corporation
with decent pay and benefits i also take
on quite a bit of contract work on the
side for various clients and my earnings
for those jobs add up to almost 50
percent of what i'm making in my
nine-to-five job these side projects
generate much more passion in me than my
day job does and i could envision myself
doing it full time i want to be patient
and set myself up for success but i feel
like i'm working two full-time jobs and
i don't want to burn out what should i
consider before making my solo venture
my primary source of income well this is
a math question
the fact that you're already making
almost 50
of your day job in this side hustle
dream job tells me that you're not very
far from making this step and i said
step not a leap and i think it comes
down to and again i said it's a math
question i think it comes down to your
comfort level you've clearly uh drew
you guys have done life the right way
with your money you have no debt except
for your home
and i would be taking if you haven't
already and i suspect george that he has
that he saved a good bit of the money
he's made from a side hustle if you have
it though drew
i would begin to put all of the money
okay i changed my budget whatever i've
been paying myself i would put all of
the money
from the side hustle back whatever you
make i'd keep it in the account we call
it retained earnings
as we teach this to companies through
ontario leadership here at ramsey
solutions and i would get to a point
where i had six to nine months of my
current salary in the bank and then i
would go i'd feel pretty comfortable
knowing i had six to nine months saved
and existing clients
coming in i think but that comes down to
you and your wife sitting down and i
think it comes down to a comfort level
yeah what is that number well we're
going to be comfortable jumping ship
here thoughts on that
i mean clearly right anything how would
you come about that one side projects
generate much more passion so what that
tells me is if they could really put the
foot on the gas with the side business
it's going full time real fast and then
they're in a great financial position if
they had loads of debt i would say hey
let's pause let's clean up this mess but
if you can get that retained earnings in
place uh and not slow down once you
leave that job and go we're comfortable
we got the savings then you're in a good
spot drew way to go that's awesome all
right we're going to ray in dallas texas
ray welcome to the ramsay
show thank you
what's going on
i'm 61 years old
i've worked for a small
or medium-sized city for about 25 years
i'm about ready to retire
but i feel like i'm trapped
at this job
because i i can't retire because of the
insurance
and so i kind of hate my job and i kind
of
like my job and i really don't know what
to do if i should just tough it out for
the next four years or
try looking for another job okay so just
to get a little bit more clarity because
i'm a bit confused with how you laid it
out uh you said you're about ready to
retire uh do you mean 65 is that what
you meant by that
65 yes okay so we're so you're
definitely in now you said you can't
retire because of the insurance so at 65
are you still saying you're not going to
be able to retire
i'm not 65 i should be able to retire or
you know
get medicare and if i want if i want to
okay i totally get it that's kind of
that's kind of another
part of the problem is
i i know myself and i know that if i
don't have anything to do i won't do
anything i agree i agree so this is
actually
if i guess it's kind of exciting ray
so i'm going to ask you a question
um let's just let's just keep this
simple for right now
i know you'd like to do it now but we'll
get to that in a second but let's just
say we fast forwarded to 65 and now
you've got the safety net of retirement
and yet you still want to do something
what would you do at 65 ray knowing you
may not have to make anywhere near what
you make now but you would just love to
go do some work that you enjoy work that
you're good at ray what would you do
that's a that's a good question i know i
really don't i really don't know because
i've been doing what i've been doing for
20 years yeah but forget all that
when i asked that question i took my
time with it i don't know if you could
tell and the reason i took my time with
it ray is i've done this
uh thousands of times with people like
you who go i don't know ken but see you
actually had a couple of things that's
kind of scrolled across your brain while
i was talking i want you to tell me what
you've wondered about but you're not
sure about
okay back when i was younger a friend of
mine and i ran kind of a
handyman business on the side yeah
and uh we would you know just handyman
business but most most of that i did
because
he and i were you know are still best
friends but he lives in in a different
part of the state now
and so
uh
you know i i don't i don't want to do
that work by myself because i've done it
by myself and it's you know
it's tedious and it's and it's difficult
but with him there we we both got
together and and you know it was it was
fun to do
but i know that you know so that's
that's kind of off off the
yeah but what did you enjoy about the
work besides hanging out with him what
did you enjoy about it
well i mean
don't overthink this it's all you're
already editing i don't know why you
need to edit this is you this is your
answer it's not ken's opinion on your
answer or george's opinion what do you
love about it
basically it was just hanging out with
him yeah really okay we had we had fun
doing the work yeah okay let me ask you
this of of your whole life has there
ever been a type of work in your whole
career a type of work a task or a role
that you play that you really did enjoy
what's easy i was a i was a peace
officer for uh a few years about 16
years yeah
and so
uh when i was thinking about retiring
i went to a small department and applied
and they said no thank you well who
cares who cares that they said well
thank you i asked you what kind of work
did you enjoy what did you love working
why did you enjoy being a peace officer
tell me give me the short answer what do
you love about it
and i was i was an investigator and i i
love doing that okay all right but you
know if i started over again and
basically i would be because it's been
over 20 years
and and i still have my my
license i would just have to get a
commission with one of the departments
but if i started over i'd have to start
over in patrol
you know okay but hold on a second but
we're assuming that's the only path what
i'm trying to help you see ray
is that there's a type of work that you
enjoy doing
okay forget about the position
and the industry i'm talking about the
work itself
so you know had you said i really like
working with my hands and solving
problems with my head and my hands i'd
go great you enjoy doing with your buddy
you're acting like your buddies the only
person ever could work alongside of you
but you could find a young 20 something
year old kid who wants to get in it
or maybe a family member who's got some
of those skills you could have done that
you could go back into a role where you
go i'm going to do investigation but i'm
going to work for an insurance agency
because i've got a peace officer and
investigative work on my resume i'm
going to go work for a local insurance
company who needs to investigate workers
comp claims or something i mean ray you
got to start looking wait a second i'm
retired i fast forwarded you to 65 where
you got income coming in now it's just
doing something that you really enjoy
and you enjoy only it doesn't matter if
you're starting over it doesn't matter
how much money you're making i enjoy it
do you get what i'm saying ray
yes so ray i'm gonna give you a homework
assignment i want you to sit with it for
a few days
what would you do what would you try
at 65 if you knew you couldn't fail
and you could quit it six weeks later
and try something else make the list of
the top two or three things start
investigating
how you would do it i think you could
get in there with and let's dream a
little bit ray you've earned it now go
do it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
stop paying your overpriced wireless
provider and switch to puretalk they use
the same network as the larger providers
for much less for just 30 a month get
unlimited talk text and six gigs of data
with no contract the average family
saves over 70 dollars a month by
switching to pure top just go to
puretalk.com and enter the promo code
ramsey to save 50 off your first month
pure talk simply smarter wireless
[Music]
this is the ramsey show i'm george
campbell joined by ken coleman today we
are taking your calls triple eight eight
two five
five two two five amber joins us in
akron ohio amber welcome to the ramsay
show
thank you hi how are you today doing
well how can can i help
um my question that i've had is related
to
my
term life insurance policy
um and my question
is basically
um it is relatively expensive annually
so when would it be a good time to
either
reapply for a
new policy or to negotiate a lower
cost
now talk to me about relatively
expensive what is uh what does it cost
annually
so i say it's relatively expensive um
because of my
medical history um
so we just paid it for the second time
last month and it was it's 548.
you just got the policy last year
that's 548 per year correct
right yeah okay so we're talking about
under 50 bucks a month
yeah that doesn't sound
astronomical to me is it uh is it a
budget issue is it a large percentage of
your income
um so
no
i just
i'm curious
because we have
um
the similar policy for my husband
and
his is less than
half the cost of mine
yeah and that's because he doesn't have
medications
right right his would be you know your
typical normal person
yeah i mean that's that's part of how
these things are priced because there is
higher risk
for the insurance company to take on
someone like you versus your husband so
that's why that rate is higher did you
shop uh independently to get this term
life in place
um
where'd you get through we went through
we actually went through
um xander so they
um you know
showed the list of options and so we
picked um whatever was the lowest one
from
then that they
okay yeah that's great i just wanted to
make sure that you didn't go with a
captive agent you know like someone my
buddy at state farm and they're only
going to give you the state farm policy
so i wanted to make sure that you shop
with an independent uh term life agent
who can help you and absolutely you can
do this once a year and contact them you
can go to ramseysolutions.com click on
trusted pros and click on term life and
uh you can try this and say hey has
anything changed based on the rates or
my condition is this uh are you
comfortable sharing what this medical
history is is this something that could
change over time sure
sure um
so what it
so for what it was um
last year when we got the policy i was
almost six years
after after this event so this is back
in 2013
september
um i was only 19.
i had
surgery to remove a benign brain tumor
how are you doing now
everything's great um so i go back
um every two years now
um for checkup mri and stuff and
i'll go back in december this year so
everything's great they gave me
you know
it's all clear free to go so they just
scheduled me to come back every two
years that's awesome
so good to hear amber well here's what i
would do if i if i was in your shoes i'm
gonna reshop this thing once a year uh
go through xander and check with them to
see if anything's changed otherwise what
i see is this is just a line item in
your budget
and this is here to protect your family
and i know insurance is not the most fun
thing to pay but what it does is it
protects you and your family and
replaces your income in case something
happened to you so if i'm you guys this
is just a budget line item like
groceries or anything else and make it a
sinking fund in your account so that
once that annual renewal is up you've
got 548 dollars sitting there ready to
pay this thing and you just yawn and you
move on right yeah that's exactly what
we do great yeah well you're you're
doing the right things and uh we're so
so grateful to hear that you're doing
better um and that you do have term life
in place super important i i this this
kind of stuff really hacks me off and i
think that if of all the crap that that
politicians are dealing with in dc on
both sides of the aisle by the way that
they can't get together and do something
about pre-existing conditions this is
garbage the amount of money that we pay
to insurance companies and i'm not
trying to say that insurance executives
are evil people they're in the business
of business
they insure us but they're in business
they they're they're they have all the
right in the world to lobby for breaks
if they want to but i got to just tell
you george
to me it's absolutely outrageous yeah
with the amount of money we play we pay
in premiums
that six years ago she had a benign
tumor taken out
and uh and she's not getting ripped off
i mean those those but still it bothers
me i gotta tell you what what's the
point of insurance i get it's like a
seinfeld thing now what's the deal with
insurance okay just you know every time
i hear this it irritates me to no end we
the people ought to stand up and just
hold these people all we can do is keep
on fighting the good fight ken we will
karen's on the line in columbia south
carolina karen welcome to the ramsay
show
thank you thanks for your help yeah
what's going on
well i think i'm getting a little
impatient um
i'm completely debt-free except my
mortgage
that's pretty awesome karen way to go
a lot of stupid mistakes for 20 years
um but i got on board maybe
three to five years ago and paid off
about
student loans and everything maybe close
to half a million dollars oh my goodness
oh karen you just sleep in on us clearly
you do have some patience
that's incredible i think it's running
out so i owe
175 000
on your mortgage on my house okay i
refinanced it paid off my student loans
did the right thing for the the interest
of course but um i want to pay it off
now
hey don't we all i get it
well you've paid off half a million
dollars so you know how to do this right
create as much margin in your budget as
possible which by the way you have all
of it now because you don't have any
debt so how much are you extra are you
putting on the mortgage every month
well that's the whole thing today i paid
off paid another ten thousand on it i
sold each condo that i owned and i put
80 000 on that about a year ago but
um so i i just can't seem to make as
quick progress as i want to so what i
want to know is
and i want to know how good a shape i'm
in too for the future but i'm 59
i have um
close to 600 000 in retirement
um
and i make between 360 and 400 a year
wow
well that's good information karen karen
so this is paid off by the within 12
months
easily
but you want to continue to take it out
of my retirement no
no no wrong answer hold on a second
george you can do the tactical stuff
because you're a money person until the
break so i know but i just got to coach
karen up in 20 seconds karen you've been
in gazelle intense for so long you've
paid off so much money you need to relax
you are in great shape how much is the
house worth tell george and i real quick
um we think we're going to sell it to
downsize a little bit but it's worth um
600.
well if you're going to downsize just
sell the house and then we take care of
the debt you can pay that off
it's a unique house i don't know when
we'll sell it no all right okay well
karen here's the thing we'll even go
through with it
i mean your take home alone you could
pay this thing off in six months but
you're saying i don't have the patience
to go another six months i'm just done
i've been doing this a long time i want
it done today is that right well i want
to be yeah but i want to be smart too
yeah well absolutely then using your
retirement money and getting hit on that
is not smart so take that off the table
you have an incredible shovel here you
don't need to touch your retirement at
all what you need to do is just find out
how much margin you can create in your
budget every month and whatever margin
you create throw that onto the mortgage
and let that fuel you to pay this thing
off but goodness these numbers are are
hopeful ken to say the least karen you
are a rock star karen you're a champion
just keep playing the plan out it's
gonna work and you're gonna get there
and it's gonna be glorious karen come
visit us to do your debt free screen
when that house is paid off i'm excited
to meet you you're a rock star way to go
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsay show i'm
george campbell joined by ken coleman
it's a free call this hour triple eight
eight two five
five two two five and we are headed to
chicago illinois to talk with thomas
thomas welcome to the ramsay show
hey it's nice to talk to you guys you as
well how can we help
so my question's kind of broad but it's
uh for ken i have a
phone screen for an internship coming up
at a large financial institution
and i'd just like to know how to leave
the best impression and basically just
ensure a call back
yeah well you know uh the simple answer
and i'm going to break this down for you
the simple answer is relentless
preparation leads to
reflexive performance
and what that simply means is that when
we put our the right information in our
brain even when we're nervous and
certainly something like this a job
interview is terrifying for so many
people it's a big performance you know
not many people like george and i we
enjoy you know being in front of large
crowds and we're just nuts but most
people are it's a terrifying proposition
to perform
um in a job interview and that's what
this is even though it's an internship
so
if you are really really prepared
and you're thinking ahead of time
through
some of the basic questions why you want
the internship
where you want to go in your career why
did you pick that company you know what
what excites you about it you know just
your general questions and you really
think through your answers and you run
them through your head
whatever that looks like for you however
you would normally prepare for a test
you're really taking the same approach
here and what will happen is is that
brain of yours is a super computer and
even in in pressure situations
anxiety-filled uh situations it's going
to perform now that's my general answer
specifically what i want you to do is i
want you to plan to go in with some
questions
and george one of the techniques that i
tell people is go in with uh with a
moleskin or something to write with pen
i'm a pencil moleskine guy but i'd have
the questions in front of me on that pad
and the reason is because that doesn't
make you look anything other than
serious
and prepared
and you can glance at those questions
and then here's the deal
write something when you ask a question
write something even you're writing i'm
really nervous but i think it's going
well i mean just be engaged but pay
attention to the to the to the answers
they give you and if you ask really good
questions thomas
it's going to separate you from the pack
and make no mistake this is a
competition so some of the questions you
need to ask are how do interns win in
this position who are how would you
describe some former interns who were
really successful in this role what made
them stand out what were their character
traits what are some of the things they
did you ask a question like that and
they're gonna go okay this guy thomas
where'd he come from he's serious did he
park his alien ship in the parking lot
uh because that's really gonna separate
you so that's the kind of stuff and i'm
gonna make sure we give you
uh in fact you can go to kencoleman.com
as soon as the call is over thomas and
in our resources uh tab at kencolma.com
there is a how to win the interview
guide it's a pdf you can download it
it's totally free and it's going to go
way deeper into the types of questions
you should ask beyond what i just gave
you and it's going to help you really
prepare but that's the key uh and if
this is a screener uh it's really no
different if it's in person it's no
different than if you're doing it on
video or over the phone i think you said
over the phone so
is that fact is that in fact what you
said it's on the phone
yeah it's a phone screen so like 20 30
minutes
yeah you know what i would recommend i
really want you to stand
i would stand during this because we
know from uh research that uh there's a
confidence that comes with standing you
sound different uh i would be you know i
wouldn't pace but uh since it's a phone
i just gave you the idea of the pad but
i would do that i would write your stuff
now because they don't see you so have
everything written down or on a screen
you know in front of you and have
everything there and go to it and and
ask good questions and if you ever get
to in person that same advice i gave you
do that in person as well
okay so then kind of a follow-up um i
don't know like the depth of which
they're going to be like asking me like
what kind of technical skills or any of
that but if it is just like a general
screening do you think and i really like
the question what does a winner look
like that stuck in my head ever since i
heard you say that but do you think
those questions are appropriate or
should i okay man listen you don't know
if you're gonna get past the screener i
wouldn't leave anything i wouldn't leave
anything in the arsenal i'd fire all the
ammunition you got
all right am i right you're in a you're
in a competition and you got to look at
it like a competition except you can't
see your competition you're not
hand-to-hand combat with them you just
got to throw your best foot forward so
yeah man blow them away but uh go to the
website
and get the how to win the interview
resource this could be a game changer
for you
okay and yeah the screen is actually um
an alum too from the college i'm going
to well okay here we go okay let me okay
real quick george so uh is there some
sort of saying
uh is there some sort of like thing
that'll bear to say to each other is
there something like that
i guess so yeah then say that right like
so for instance i'm a michigan fan so
anywhere in the world if i run into a
michigan fan i go go blue and they say
go blue so whatever it is for your
college i'd lead with that yeah and he
goes oh uh you went you know me like
like you know hey what years were you
there like break the ice a little bit
with that mutual connection do you
understand what i'm saying
yeah all right you got this man thanks
for that that's great you know ken i
started as an intern here and i remember
doing so much research and i had the
word document in front of me on the call
i barely needed any of the research we
didn't cover it but i felt so prepared
yeah because i had it and i knew the
company i knew the numbers i knew
exactly what they were all about and you
know that's partially how i got into a
full-time job well take us back to the
internship because now you're you're you
know you're in your dream gig here dude
yeah i mean you're co-hosting the second
largest radio show in the world i never
thought i came in as an intern so can i
interview you real quick yeah
what were your emotions like from a
confidence level like it's a
nerve-wracking thing but because you
were so prepared do you remember
i do like how did it play out my
confidence well my memory our leader
jeremy breland uh his father uh worked
at university of mobile which is where i
graduated college so we had an instant
connection just like thomas did so you
dropped it in there and so we dropped in
and said hey you know i actually
graduated from the university of mobile
and i know your dad and breelan i
thought there was a connection
and that was one of the first
conversations i had and i was also so
passionate about this internship yeah i
had they were like you're going to move
to nashville for a two-month internship
and i said yeah i'll do whatever it
takes
i love this kind of work and i'm
dreaming about doing this kind of thing
and here's here's the strategy i worked
up just to give you guys a taste of what
i'm excited about to do for and you
start dreaming about and they go whoa
this guy's an interesting so i don't you
just you just ran right over that so you
had a you had a little bit of a plan
that you wanted to
and you shared it with them and it just
it blows their mind i said here's where
i've seen you get you guys are here i
want to take you here and i feel like i
can add value in these areas and here's
the numbers that i think we could see
increase by doing these specific
strategies and i think they were like
whoa well first of all they were and let
me tell you something young people i
mean that's brilliant what george just
shared and here's why
internships the very nature of them
you're trying to get in so that you can
get something experience
connections right yeah
you were coming in going yeah i want to
get those things but here's what i'm
going to give you all
yeah dude i'm a little bit like
way after the fact going out of boy
george yeah this was perfect 2013.
textbook yeah so that's really what got
me the internship and they said well
let's get you a temp job you already
graduated so i did a temp job over in
social media and i just tried to you
know really excel at whatever was in
front of me just get a little more rope
and a little more rope and uh that led
me into all kinds of jobs into into this
one ken which as you would say is the
sweet spot yeah getting to do this kind
of work yeah you know we get a lot of
questions on the ken coleman show about
interviews and i just i want to revisit
what i share with that young man because
i think we over
complicate
performing well in an interview and i
think it really is george as simple as
just be prepared read that job
description so many times that you could
recite it backwards and as you're
reading it you get so familiar with it
you begin to go where does my talents
plug into this job description
where am i passionate about the stuff
included in this job description
how are the results that this company
produces yeah
a product or a service that's that's all
that the options are how does it connect
to my personal values
when you think about all of that stuff
and you're really familiar with the job
description and we're assuming here that
you actually are a good fit for it sure
okay
the conversation pieces and the
confidence that you'll have in those
moments because you're so locked into
this thing you're a mini expert in the
very job that you're applying for yeah
that's a huge game changer yeah
incredible well thomas we're pulling for
you man good luck with this interview
hope you land the internship hope you uh
you use ken's clear path to get to that
dream job that puts this hour of the
ramsey show in the books i want to thank
our phone screener jenna our producer
ben hill in the booth we'll be back with
you before you know it until then spend
wisely save intentionally and give
generously
[Music]
hey it's kelly associate producer and
phone screener for the ramsay show if
you would like to do your debt free
scream live on the show make sure you
visit the ramsey show dot com and
register we would love for you to come
to nashville and tell dave your story
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studio it's the ramsay show
where america hangs out to have a
conversation about your life and money
and career and purpose relationships and
everything else under the sun i'm george
campbell and i'm joined today by ramsay
personality and best-selling author ken
coleman it's a free call triple eight
eight two five
five two two five charlotte is with us
in dallas texas charlotte welcome to the
ramsay show
hi guys i um i kind of try to do this
without crying
um so i'm kind of in a crazy situation
i have money to spend um i've been
following the dave ramsey plans for
three years and i am
um in
pause baby step four
and
i um
ran away
from a bad situation four weeks ago
and i'm actually not in dallas
okay because i ran away um but i
ran away from a bad situation
and um
i've been on the road for four weeks
airbnb
is trying to find a place to land and i
found a safe place to land where i can
get some medical care it turns out i was
medically starved
and so i'm dealing with the trauma or
that i left the trauma that i've had on
the road getting in my car so night
because i don't didn't have a place to
stay and didn't know where i'd been for
night tonight
oh sweet charlotte were you what are you
running from an abusive relationship
um that and
yes so i started over and in the process
i discovered just how bad things were
and so
now i need to establish my four walls i
just know that
i'm not able to start my healing because
i'm not in a like my body doesn't feel
safe without a home and so i want to
rent something
but where i am where it's safe and the
help that i need is
um
i'm just
there are rentals
but i'm having trouble like
processing
spending all the money and
like the help that i need is very
delicate so it's to cost me money my
insurance doesn't cover it
um so it's going to be self-pay it's
worth it to me to live
but i don't know how much that is and
then i'm just like so terrified to spend
my money because i think it's gonna just
like
i don't want to waste it i know that i'm
not like in the best of mental frames
because it feels so urgent and when it's
urgent i make bad decisions okay so i
want to make a good decision like on a
safe
um quiet place to to rent but i'm scared
to rent for a year because i'm scared of
getting stuck
and i also i'm like
i have
forty thousand dollars they get for down
payment on the house and i have my
fifteen thousand dollar emergency fund
but i'm scared to spend any money
to find a place to go right surely and i
don't know
i don't wanna get like um you know i
don't want people to think oh
we can take advantage of her and make
her pain more than she needs to so it's
like
how do i how do i get my four walls in
place
make sure that it
safe and i body can heal in that space
sure and then get real started get
serious on my journey okay so all right
so charlotte couple things i'm gonna
george i'm gonna have george just kind
of walk you through the four walls
you're in such good shape financially
honestly
i'm so scared to i'm getting you don't
get to waste all my money wait a second
okay all right so hold on what if i need
that for the treatment hold on a second
all right so i'm actually going to stay
with you
well hold on and i can help you with
that
so
i feel like you used to worry i get it
so you've landed in an area in a city
where you've got some relationships is
that is that what i'm understanding
well the people are very kind and i'm
getting help okay great so i'm going to
walk you through a couple quick
questions and and george can can help
out on the financial stuff but you're
actually in really good shape so i'm
going to kind of help you out on all
this fear of getting this wrong i know
but listen listen i'm really like what
if i have to go away and i can't
you know just
i have to what if i wasn't meant to be
here okay hold on a second so let's just
let's first first of all you've got to
get healthy and you already know what
treatment you need have you have you
gotten a quote on it have you run the
numbers on it is to an actual cost
oh no not yet because
it's kind of like
it just happened yesterday and there's a
lot of unknowns about what i really do
need because
it's so complicated okay
but you have seen a medical professional
yeah that's what you mean by it just
happened yesterday
yeah okay so
did they tell you about how long it
would be before you're gonna get some
type of a plan and a
response got a plan um but again
it's unknown the cost
okay all right so we'll see i think
again with them on tuesdays they're
working with me i think they have some
financial aid at their office okay great
all right second question are you
physically able to work i know you've
been through a lot right now but are you
physically able to work
i would love to say yes but honestly at
this point i'm so weak yeah i don't know
when i can i leave 58 pounds oh sweet
charlotte
okay listen sweetheart
first of all
you have a fifteen thousand dollar
emergency fund
you have forty thousand dollars that
you've been holding aside
for a house that's we're not gonna we're
not even thinking about a house
and you can't work right now so the good
news is kelly told me that you're safe
and you're in a place where you've got
some nice people and you're seeing a
medical professional your entire focus
right now sweetheart is is getting your
body rebooted
with the medical professionals putting
weight back on and then the next step is
going to be
getting the counseling that you need
because you've been through something
extremely
traumatic okay
but um but listen but i'm not going to
spend it okay
then get it listen to me okay i'm sorry
this airbnb is causing me trauma as it
is because it's like and on october 17th
i don't have anywhere else to go i know
listen charlotte i agree and you said
you had a fear
of signing an apartment lease that you
were gonna get taken advantage of and
then you said your other fear is well
what if i get stuck in this place for 12
months that is the least of your worries
that's the least of your worries okay so
you need to get an apartment go find a
really nice apartment okay nothing
exorbitant nothing crazy but also in a
really nice i don't need anything i just
need something simple well then do that
then do that you have the money you have
been amazing you had forty thousand
dollars you saved for a house just go
get an apartment put the full year down
and uh
and don't worry about it can i use that
but can i use that for my
um
medical care all right here's what we're
gonna do charlotte there's a lot to
unpack here we gotta do a commercial
break please hold don't go anywhere just
in a few minutes we're going to come
back and we're going to unpack the next
financial steps for you as well okay so
hang in there we'll be right back
[Music]
[Music]
if you're considering a career in
technology i recommend bethel tech and
i'm not alone here's what brendan said
before bethel tech i was driving uber
within four months of graduating i got a
job paying 60 000
about two years after that i got a
remote job that pays me a hundred and
thirty thousand dollars all thanks to
what i learned at bethel tech you could
be next get started today at
betheltech.net
and get one thousand to twenty five
hundred dollars off of your tuition
again it's betheltech.net
ken coleman
[Music]
so
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsey show before
the break we were on the phone with
charlotte in dallas and she was
unpacking uh heartbreaking situation
leaving a toxic relationship trying to
get back on her feet
medically trying to find a place to land
and we've got her on the line here
charlotte are you still with us
i'm still here
okay
so where we left off ken was walking you
through your financial side and letting
you know that you are more than okay
financially you have 55 000 in cash is
that correct
yes okay
that gives me a lot of hope on that side
obviously there's a lot more here where
you need to get back on your feet and a1
to me is finding an apartment
now you have no income
and so you might need to look at a
non-traditional
renting situation maybe with a family
they've got uh or someone who's just
renting a room or a house somewhere safe
in your area that you can i've tried
that for two weeks and nothing has shown
up and i've asked around
and most people have given me names of
brokers so i just need to i felt like
i just needed to sit down because they
asked me for numbers and i don't know
the housing market so it's like i don't
know what to tell them
i don't want to overshoot it numbers as
far as what
what do you want to pay for money
i mean
there's none of that they're gonna say
hey the place is a thousand dollars a
month and you say okay yeah you need a
nice safe apartment community and a nice
area that makes you feel safe
and
you just go and say i need the a one
bedroom apartment and what's it called
reasonable
well i don't we obviously we don't know
where you actually are
but you can do some research do some
googling in your area to find out what
is the average apartment costing
i don't want you to be worried about
being taken advantage of i mean it's not
going to be four thousand dollars a
month unless you're in new york city and
trying to rent in manhattan so
right now i don't want you to be
researching for four weeks i want you to
get an apartment this week and land
somewhere so that you can get better
tell them
just tell them what i want in one
because i know what i want what do you
mean what do you want
i want something that's
safe
quiet
and private
okay and simple it doesn't have
even if it's just like one of those
houses that's split in two sure sure
well this is you live in one side well
this is you going on these websites
there's all of there's all kinds of i
mean you doing your research in less
than three hours
to a broker and so if they ask me
because each one has an application fee
so that's my thing is like how many do i
apply for only apply for the stuff that
you've looked at online and it's it's 50
dollars you have 55 000 you're not gonna
apply to 48 apartments so what you need
to do is know your area and know what
are the safe parts of this of the
neighborhoods and what's a good
place at reviews yeah so if you know
that you know what area i would like to
live in then go over there sweetheart
and walk in and say i'd like to tour
like to look at a couple of apartments
that's very normal and they're going to
walk you through and you have to walk in
the apartment you don't have to do an
application fee to walk in an apartment
look at it pick the apartment that you
want and the reason we're helping you
with this charlotte is because this is
what's most important this is money you
have to spend so that you have a safe
place to land so that the medical
healing and then the mental and
emotional healing can take place and you
have enough money to take care of a year
and not even lose sleep over it and then
you can say i just moved to the area
they don't care they just want to know
that you can pay for your rent and then
you you're going to get on your feet
working once you physically and
emotionally can you got to do this first
that's so true because i want to work i
know and you will
you will
so so charlotte a1 is the apartment and
once you land there you've got a safe
place that's going to give you
room to heal and focus on your physical
health your mental health all these
components and i know it's tough because
you don't want to pay all these medical
bills but if you don't have income
coming in there's there should be a lot
of financial aid involved especially
with self pay
you're not going to pay the standard
rate that me and ken would pay with our
own health insurance so make sure you're
working with that medical professional
and get a lay of the land of what this
treatment is going to take how long it's
going to take how expensive it might be
and it is worth it i don't care if you
drained all of that money down to a
thousand dollars it would still be worth
it if it means that you get healthy yeah
that's a1 so once you've got the
apartment and you've got your health
back then we can work on the job and
obviously ken is is the expert in that
arena but right now that's not your a1
so i don't want you losing sleep over
the what am i going to do for the next
20 years with my job and the house stuff
i know you were so excited you've worked
so hard i mean you're incredible to save
up 40 000 for a down payment in your
situation but you're going to get that
40 000 again down the road for that down
payment but right now that money needs
to be allocated towards you getting
better towards you funding uh this
apartment rent fee
and then we can talk about that and what
i want to do for you is get you
connected to a financial coach
in your area so i'm going to have kelly
pick up and we're going to cover the
cost for you you're not going to spend a
dime on this and these are financial
coaches that have been trained the
ramsey way and they're going to help
walk you through this in way more detail
than me and ken uh will be able to on a
radio call they'll sit down with you for
90 minutes they can do it remotely over
zoom if you're more comfortable with
that they'll do this on your terms and
they can really walk with you along this
journey because we want to see you get
better and we want to see you heal and
be back to
uh to 100
okay so let me get this straight anyone
in his apartment it really doesn't
matter how much
i'm like look obviously i'll know what's
reasonable with this
cost of living
um and then
a2 is
getting cost and how much it's your
health focus on your health your mental
health your physical health and getting
that taken care of i just have to
to believe that the right run the right
apartment will be there for me and it
will be available oh absolutely
absolutely will be the thing the
availability yeah but listen it's out
there and charlotte you need to
acknowledge something that you have been
under unbelievable
unspeakable
uh
hardship and what you're going through
and naturally you're really really
scared right now and you're just walking
around feeling like there's a monster
around every corner i feel yes and i
feel like i'm in
it's so hard to believe that this is
actually me because i'm just so
traumatized i know i know i can't even
see myself in the mirror i know but
listen
and so after you get physically healthy
then you can go back to work and then we
work on them on the emotional and the
mental stuff you've gone through you're
gonna need counseling and therapy but
listen it's worth it
charlotte if you hear anything today
would you please hear
that you didn't do anything wrong you
have nothing to be guilty of and you
matter so deeply to so many people in
this world but you have got to believe
that enough to get healthy okay and you
spend with yourself like i messed
everything up and i'm so scared of
getting panicked because i know what bad
decisions i make it's open listen to
them
you're still on the phone talking to us
you're still on the phone talking to us
you're still here
and you still matter
okay so you decide
to get healthy
you got it
and you got this despite all of the
things you're beating yourself up about
george is right you got 55 000
that's nothing to sneeze at you got this
kiddo we're praying for you get healthy
get healthy get healthy get healthy
and then
then we start the climb
back into the full charlotte being who
you were created to be and when you get
to that point you call the ken coleman
show and i'll help you you understand
got it all right charlotte do you have
any any friends or community right now
in your area
i have one friend
one friend are they are they a safe
friend that you can that they they can
walk with you through this journey
yeah
okay good awesome i want you to have
that community that is so important and
it may be at a local church in your area
that you can show up and get plugged
into um you need people supporting you
right now i mean you're a very strong
person on your own but it's going to be
a game changer to have those people
walking
what's that anymore
it's hard to know who to trust anymore i
know it's like that
yeah like i also just need some privacy
to this process yep absolutely well
remember your uh your game plan here
step one is apartment step two is your
health and step three is getting income
back in your life with a job but right
now um you've got to get all this taken
care of and get you a safe place to land
and kelly's going to pick up she's going
to take care of her
go after what's that
i need to do it
[Music]
food shelter utilities transportation if
you've got those covered everything else
is gravy after that kelly's gonna pick
up we're gonna get you connected with a
financial coach we are cheering for you
praying for you all of america is right
now you've got the charlotte
[Music]
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners we're
intentional about choosing the best
advertisers to recommend blinds.com is
no exception they offer high quality
window treatments at unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
shades and interior shutters with easy
online ordering free shipping and a
guaranteed perfect fit go to blinds.com
and take advantage of this week's
special savings
[Music]
[Music]
this is the ramsay show i'm george
campbell joined by my friend ken coleman
ken i'm really excited about
this book you've got coming out from
paycheck to purpose and the reason i'm
excited is because i see all over the
news these days this idea of the great
resignation people all over the country
are going i don't know if i want to work
here or live here or do this thing and
this book is just monumental in helping
people during this time especially well
thanks and you know it is a clear path
you know the the for for ramsay show
listeners that that come to us for the
financial advice obviously the baby
steps uh is a clear path and this book
from paycheck to purpose the clear path
to doing work you love is the clear path
to doing what you love and making the
money you want to make so income impact
meaning money whatever you want to say
there that's why we it titled it that
because everybody longs to do something
that they're good at that they enjoy
that creates a result that matters to
them that's talent passion mission and
so we go from stage one that's get clear
all the way to give yourself away where
the money's there the notoriety whatever
you want to achieve
but the contribution that every person
longs to make is there and so
the book is the clear path and it's for
anybody uh whether or not you just hey i
just want to run a small business one
day or you know what i just i've been a
stay-at-home mom and i think i want to
be an admin assistant and and because i
love that kind of work and i can make
some money and help pay for college or
what whatever
this book is for you and uh if you go to
ramseysolutions.com you can pre-order it
it comes out november the 9th as you
know george and
we've got over 100 in free bonus tools
the resume templates guides a video
course that'll coach you through the
interview process the e-book the
audiobook all of that for an amazing low
price
just to incentivize you to buy this for
yourself or maybe for a family member or
friend who's going i want to make the
move too but i'm scared to death well
this book is the clear path takes the
fear out of it because it's a stage by
stage process so it's called from
paycheck to purpose you can get it right
now we'll come to you on november the
9th when it comes out
ramseysolutions.com store a lot of
goodies there ken super pumped for you
love your heart behind this thing it's
going to help a lot of people all right
let's go to the phones we've got james
in houston james welcome to the ramsay
show
hey guys excited to talk to you as well
my wife and i my wife and i about two
and a half years ago started on the baby
steps or actually started on the uh the
debt snowball uh in october or this
month we're going to pay that off and be
done with that
completely through with uh yeah we're
excited man we'll also be through with
the uh the three to six months worth of
uh expenses saved before the end of the
year and so
we're skipping the college thing all our
kids are already in college we're not
going to do that but we're going to move
on to the the next step and they've
suggested we put in 15 start putting 15
to our employer
uh retirement funds we've done a little
bit of math and as it turns out we both
have a roth 457 available to us through
our employer
and
our pencil paper shows us if we max that
out first instead of putting just 15
percent in and then pay off the house
after we
um or continue paying on the house but
it will cause the house to be paid off
two years later
but then we end up with about 60 to 80
grand more at the end of the time period
we're thinking of which is about 10
years when i retire and so i'm just kind
of curious if we're missing something
there or if there is
if there's some room to tweak this a
little bit in terms of how much we're
putting towards the house versus
maxing out the roth iras with our
employer
okay well first of all congrats on
getting through baby step two very soon
and baby step three you guys are
crushing it uh and for baby step four
that's where we say invest fifteen
percent i know you were saying uh the
college part but that actually goes
after baby step four so you said you're
not worried about that the kids are
already in college they're doing well
and so you're then moving on to baby
step six after we've invested 15 into
those retirement accounts then we start
paying off the house early but what
you're saying if i'm hearing you
correctly is can i change the baby steps
and can i invest more now and let the
house pay off come later
yeah the house payoff will be delayed by
two years from what it would be
otherwise
uh
if we max out this this 457 we have with
both of our both of our employers
it's two years worth more more worth of
a house payment but when we do the
numbers in the end after the ten year of
matching this stuff out and then you
know with the delay in the house we come
out a little bit ahead about
80 grand ahead versus if we went
15 percent and everything else to the
house and paid off the house two years
so on paper it's looking real appetizing
yes yeah so uh how old are you guys
i'm 50 my wife's uh much younger
good answer
boy
so so she she's got a few more years to
retire than than i do i'm thinking about
10 years or so before i run a route i'm
52. i'm retiring about 10 years
in those 50 years of your life have you
ever had a paid 4 house
negative no what would it feel like
to have a paid for house and no more i'm
just curious have you thought about the
feeling
yes uh and and uh it would feel
unbelievable obviously and it would be
uh
you know it
for me it's kind of it seems like kind
of a safety net in case something
catastrophic were to happen to not have
any debt whatsoever
two years sooner uh versus two years
later but i just don't want to i don't
want to
i don't want to react emotionally here
if the bottom line is the bottom line of
60 to 80 grand more that we'll get by
matching these things out earlier with
the compounding interest and stuff like
that would be
if i'm not missing something no i saw
the speech here's the thing on paper
you're right our plan you go hey hold on
hold on why are you even paying off debt
why are you even paying off the house
you should take the money you would pay
off the house with and invest all that
in the market you could make way more
and you start to get ahead of yourself
and the thing with our plan is that it's
not all about math it's about behavior
it's about progress it's about
motivation it's about legacy and so what
i want for you guys is to follow the
steps in the order that we teach which
is do your 15
and then all that extra margin which by
the way you'll have more of if you're
not investing extra to pay off the house
even earlier than two years now you've
got a freedom house payment that you can
now add on top of your investing that
you didn't have before
so you have way more margin once this
mortgage is out of your life and you're
going to make up a whole lot of ground
on your investing as it keeps growing
for the next 10 to 20 years
yeah i feel like we we've sort of
accounted for that where we're
accounting for for the adding the
investment into
uh into what you know the investment we
were making in the house once that's
paid for into the other stuff and what
that would be if it was two years
delayed and so we're looking at having
the house paid off in four years or so
versus six years that we max out now and
then maxing out once and once the house
paid off in six years in that in that
scenario taking the money from the house
and maxing it out uh you know investing
that too as well instead of
you know just just what we're doing now
to pay it off but i i get what you're
saying and i believe that uh
i understand it and i believe you
explained that the benefit of uh
sticking strictly to the
to the baby steps so well i'm going to
harken back to one of my favorite dave
quotes
your income is your greatest wealth
building tool
and right now you don't have your income
completely you don't have 100 of the
money that you work so hard for and so
when you pay off that mortgage how much
is your mortgage every month
2100 2100
so we're talking 25 grand back in your
life
for the rest of your life that you were
paying a bank to make their buildings
bigger
i don't know about you but i want to get
angry at this thing i want to get angry
at the interest we're paying i want to
get angry at this 21 grand that's going
to banks and then you're going to let
that 2100 fuel your
investing for the rest of your life and
you're going to set yourself up for
success you're going to be able to
retire earlier because of following
these principles now
you can do james's plan i'm not mad at
you you're a great guy i'd love to hang
out with you sometime but if you're
gonna follow the ramsay plan the proven
tried and true method that millions have
done and you want to build wealth and
you want to leave a legacy
just do it the ramsey way but it's up to
you you ask for my advice and it's worth
what you paid for it ken what do you
think die that was beautiful george i
love hearing you do your thing i i i
think that uh it does come down to james
yeah he's not i mean the guy is
disciplined he's in good shape you're
not in shambles either way i think it
comes out of what do you want most yeah
i always break it down
yeah let me let me say thank you guys
and and one last thing my wife heard you
say go blue earlier she says oh h oh oh
no this is where i put him on hold
we let a buckeye sneak in on the show i
didn't hang up early enough oh my gosh
good stuff this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
our scripture of the day comes from
first corinthians 2 9.
it is written what no eye has seen what
no ear has heard and what no human mind
has conceived the things god has
prepared for those who love him
jk rowling says it is impossible to live
without failing at something unless you
live so cautiously that you might as
well not have lived at all in which case
you fail by default
love a jk rowling quote after first
corinthians can it might be a first for
me yeah it's quite a combo there i'm
here for it we got open phone lines
triple eight eight two triple what is
that number that's right triple eight
eight two five five two two two five i
just had a brain fart there it happens
you know it's been a fun show but it's
been a long one ken with you
we're going it's my fault david is in
memphis tennessee david welcome to the
ramsey show
thank you for taking my call absolutely
what's up
well i've got a question is when does
someone stop paying for term life
insurance
well or do they ever
what's what's your particular situation
well i am 57 okay and my wife is 55
and i think that we've gone through the
all the steps
and so i'm at a point of
uh we're paying for just under 200 bucks
a month for coverage for both of us okay
and
we're
we're financially stable enough to where
i don't think that
you know
financially we wouldn't be
killed if one of us or excuse me
financially we wouldn't be hurting if
one i was passed away
and so i'm wondering if the 200 a month
should be going to something else
what kind of a life insurance is this
uh term like in terms of 65
and so i'm 57 and she's 55 so
it you know i i think at that point it
it goes up i believe or that's when it
starts costing a lot more maybe when is
this actual term up for both of you when
you let's say it would be
eight years for me and ten years for my
wife so you got this term life in place
uh a little older in life
yeah well no we we had it for a while
and then uh we bumped up the numbers
and got it a little bit cheaper uh
probably three or four years ago okay
and you're paying 200 bucks a month
right now and you're saying hey could we
free up that money if what we call if
you're self-insured that's what you're
asking how do you know when yourself
yeah well it's pretty simple the
equation is this you're self-insured
when you're able to fund your family's
life not make them rich but just you're
keeping all the bills paid through the
money you have in savings and investment
accounts and all that stuff and what
you're saying is hey i think we're in a
good place financially where if we cut
this life insurance out we are
self-insured
yes and you've run the numbers on that
to say hey we've got 600 000
across our financial portfolio so if
something happened you know we could we
could take that money out invest it and
take out ten percent and survive yes
yeah yeah i'm right now we've got right
at 700 000 invested okay and we have zoo
and we have zero debt
fantastic and what baby step are you on
uh i think the last one so you have no
mortgage
no mortgage fantastic so you guys are
baby step seven
you don't have a payment in the world
other than your normal utilities and
food and all that good stuff and you've
got are you enjoying your life what's it
like yes and enjoying life and and we're
still saving money which is good yeah
but
i'm looking at the two hundred dollars
wondering if if we need to save more
instead of putting it towards life well
okay couple things can i jump in here
david first of all man congratulations
baby step seven you guys are great
you're you're acting like you're gazelle
intense all of a sudden over the 200
bucks for term life i think it comes
down to this you have to sit there and
run the numbers if you die tomorrow
okay and you didn't have the life
insurance
you just have to look at what your wife
would have to live off of
and you got to run the numbers what if
she lived 20 more years
yes
if you had no life insurance which by
the way you do right now
and it's really stinking cheap david
and it is so and so are you
just keep it yes i would keep it because
i don't think i don't think you have a
huge i mean
do you feel comfortable let's just put
you to the test you know your numbers if
you die tomorrow and you didn't have
life insurance as young as your wife is
do you feel like she can live
comfortably for the rest of her life
based on what you have right now
i think she could however it would sure
it may help if she had another you know
four hundred thousand dollars sitting in
the bank it would give her a little more
security then there's your answer david
okay yeah the 2400 a year that you guys
are spending on this i feel like right
now as well we're totally worried to
give you guys that peace of mind the
security uh it's not a huge line item in
your budget where it's crushing you guys
you have all the margin in the world
right so i'd hang on to it for now uh
you guys are baby steps millionaires i
assume
uh we're really close they're really
close but listen by the time you're 65
if the amount of money you're going to
continue to save between now and then
okay
i mean dude then you don't need to renew
it right then i don't think you need it
but i think right now i'd keep it
absolutely way to go david it's
inspiring to hear stories like that ken
people are doing some things right
that's amazing i'm here for it all right
we're going to collin in cincinnati
colin welcome to the ramsay show
hello thank you for having me how are
you guys doing great how can we help
um so i was recently awarded a
scholarship that covers my tuition and
it also awards me twenty five thousand
dollars a year or two thousand dollars
per month
and i currently have seven thousand
dollars in savings and i was wondering
what i should be doing with the money
that i will be saving with the
scholarship way to go young man that's a
pretty big deal let's get past a little
celebration
wow
thank you so is this a full ride
uh yes yeah
and then you've got twenty five thousand
dollars that's driving you on top of
that
yeah what did you do man you won the
lottery
yeah i really did yeah my dad reminds me
about it every day
he's a good dad yeah so uh what can you
use this 25 000 on what are the
stipulations of this money
well so currently my monthly expenses
are around 900 a month i have an
apartment um and then
aside from that i'm including 900
um nine hundred dollars is including
rents and groceries that i spend per
month so i'm profiting about a thousand
dollars a thousand one hundred dollars
per month but what joe what george is
asking you are there limitations can you
use this
on anything can you save it up and buy a
car or does it have to go towards
education expenses
no i can use it towards anything
wow this is wild stuff ken
right up your alley buddies give him a
plan so uh you are are you about to head
into college where are you at with that
journey
i am currently a junior and i'll be i my
expected graduation date is in 2024.
2024 okay so how many how many years is
this because that i'm not it's not
adding up for me is this a longer than a
four-year program
it is it's a five-year program okay and
what are you what are you majoring
what's the degree
it's an information technology and
software development nice this kit's
gonna be all right ken yeah i think so
this is great news you're asking what do
i do with the extra 1100 100 a month
right
right well the best investment you can
make until you graduate obviously you're
going to go to college debt-free it
sounds like for the rest of your college
career right
yep so what i would do if i was you i
would sock away that money in a savings
account nothing crazy don't go investing
this money and pile this money up so
that when you graduate you know what you
have a pile of money
and you can start your adult life and
maybe you might be that weird kid who
pays cash for a home or that guy who's
23 24 years old and is putting down a
crazy big down payment and starting off
his life in a great way instead of
struggling under the weight of student
loan debt like millions of americans so
if i'm you i'm not getting crazy with it
uh i mean enjoy some of it don't i mean
you know you're in college have some fun
but i would try to sock away you know
five six seven hundred dollars whatever
you're comfortable with that uh for that
margin to just suck away in a savings
account maybe a money market account a
high yield savings account with an
online bank you'll probably get about a
half a percent so the point of this is
not to get fancy and make a lot of money
the point is to just create a pile of
money that you can start your adult life
with
okay um
is there a big purchase that i should be
saving up for as in like big pictures um
do you have a car
um yes
my parents paid for it so wonderful i've
got a free car right now other than a
house i mean your car and your house are
going to be the biggest ticket items i
can't think of anything where you're
going all right i mean you may want to
furnish the house once you move into it
things like that uh but i would just
save that up make sure you have that
three to six months of expenses saved up
in a savings account and that you're
investing your 15 once you graduate
you've got that job but man you're doing
so great i'm just yeah this is like a
humble brand ken i'm here for it way to
we're proud of you man that puts this
hour of the ramsey show in the books i
want to thank jenna and kelly our phone
screeners ben hill our producer ken
coleman for our being a great co-host
today and you america thanks for tuning
in until next time spend wisely save
intentionally and give generously
[Music]
this is james childs producer of the
ramsay show you can listen to all our
shows with the ramsay network app on
your smartphone browse by topic or even
sync clips to your friends
download the ramsey network app in your
favorite app store today
[Music]
you